welcome everyone this is pi data hamburg
this is the may edition
may 2021 of our
we have two exciting talks for you
tonight what you should know before we
get started is that we are recording
this session
and we're going to publish it on pi
data's youtube channel so
we encourage you to participate in a q a
session on camera and on microphone
just keep in mind that you're going to
be on the internet this way
if you don't want to be with your voice
in your picture you can always ask in
the chat and we're going to read the
questions from the chat
to the speakers
so pi data is a global community for
developers and users of open source data
tools
and pi data is also an educational
program of num focus which is a
non-profit
registered in the us here you have a few
links to stay up to date
with pi data content i can highly
recommend the
youtube channel there's always great
resources on data science and the open
source data tools there
[Music]
so my name is christian i'm a data
scientist and pi data organizer and i'm
going to host this tonight
uh together with uh micropolitics nahin
hi everyone eisen
and this is the full team currently all
volunteers from pilot
hamburg maria uh camilla supporting us
today in the background this particular
meetup is
sponsored by ibm so thank you very much
ibm for sending some money to num focus
to support
open source data tool development here i
pass over to
tim who's going to tell you about the
ibm data science community
yes welcome everyone um yeah it's our
pleasure to support pi data we're a big
fan
and have been working with them last
year and again much
more closely this year to support the
international conferences and also the
local some of the local meetups
and we do have our own community and a
pretty big data science
bucket on there the ibm data science
community um over 17
000 people uh definitely recommend you
check it out
at community.ibm.com and if you join we
have a couple of goodies for you
you can either get a menu live project
or you can get some select courses for
free for one month on coursera so
definitely check out those two links
um camilla also just posted them into
the chat um
yeah give it a look uh lots of learning
sharing some lots of ibm's lots of open
source
ibmers that do work on various exciting
data
science and ai open source projects so
uh give it a look
and enjoy the event i'll have to go to
another thing right now i'll be back
about
40 minutes so thank you so much
thanks again to ibm for supporting open
source
welcome see you team part
so other than the occasional sponsorship
pi data is completely driven by
volunteers all the chapters are
self-organized
and volunteers keep them going
so every meetup has a call for
participation
so if you're might consider speaking to
us about
interesting things that you're doing
with open source data tools or
developing such open source data tools
then come talk to us
we especially encourage speakers from
underrepresented groups and first-time
speakers so we're going to help
you prepare your first pi data talk
we also always open to volunteers who
help us with meetup planning
speaker outreach outreach with a
welcoming community
just talk to us if you can imagine
helping us with this
so here i hand over to sahin who
introduced
our first speaker
hello everyone uh i think those of you
who joined early already
had a conversation with mendita we are
very pleased to have mandita today as
our first
speaker she is a data scientist
from ireland which is amazing one of the
parks of this rather
regretful pandemic but she is going to
present us and we're very happy about it
none of the stages of yours
thank you so much for introducing me and
giving this opportunity as my data
uh for my this project and
first i would like to say a very warm
welcome to everyone and say hi to
everyone i hope you all are keeping
yourself safe and
and be safe and wherever you are and
i would like to give my brief
introduction i'm nandita sharma i'm from
india currently i'm living in ireland
and i've recently completed my master's
in the international national college of
ireland
and i'm currently working as a teaching
assistant at national college of ireland
only and i have over a three year of
experience as analytics and data hinds
and so here today a very warm welcome a
very hurtful welcome from me for
attending this
uh this my presentation
and i will i will keep it very short and
crisp
so that you can understand the things in
easy and simpler way
and i will try to keep it uh as simple
as possible so now they are as i can see
they are non-technical
audience as well they can understand in
easy and simpler way about the
techniques
so here i will be sharing my screen to
all of you hope you can see my screen
yes we can yeah
um
can you all see my screen just gives
thumbs up if it is available clearly
okay fine so
here i start my project um
in this presentation i will be taking
you to the loan defaulter prediction
model using machine learning techniques
uh this is like
uh in this like this project which
basically uh
shows how the machine learning technique
is being used to predict
the loan defaulter in the future
so here i start
so coming to the introduction first i
will like to do what is the loan
defaulter and how it's
uh being a big fix for financial
financial
banking everyone like me you every
individual all across the globe
is some and somehow are dependent on the
banks
they we all used to take we all used to
take loans we all take loans for various
reasons
whether whether some take loans for the
education purpose it
some take loan for the financial
constraints say some
take loans for the educational purpose
and they all have their some personal
goals and they take loans from the banks
and this process is very invertible
process
and with ever increasing competition and
changing and economy
in a financial world and this activity
has become a very
uh invertible process and everyone is
taking in loans and they all are
dependent on banks and banks are
dependent on
the people's so and also the small
businesses
large businesses when we talk about
large business small business skills
they also depend on activity of lending
out the loans to earn a profit
in terms of for managing their affairs
second in function of this in in smooth
functioning of the financial constraints
so therefore uh this lending loans
basically is a major source of income
for the bank
as well as it is a biggest source of
financial rig for the
brics for the bank as well
major uh portion of a banking assets
like that it directly come from the
investment earned from various loan
which they used to in which they give to
their
customers and this lending loan is very
quite beneficial for both the parties
like it's really beneficial for the
person who is taking the loan as well
and it is also beneficial for the bank
who is giving the loan but it also
consists of the high risks
uh so yeah so where i was uh so
basically
the lending loan it is beneficial for
both the parties it is beneficial for
the person who is taking the loan as
well and it is a beneficial person
for the bank as well and but it also
comes with a great risk
and the risks is basically incapable of
borrowers to pay back the loan
uh in in in design time frame
so that is the biggest rick for the bank
they give a loan but
they don't get it back on the estimated
amount of time or
that is the biggest tricks for the bank
so yeah
so it's very important uh to the uh x to
access the client credit suitability a
very be
before the authorizing loan so basically
when i talk about the credit score it is
a score which
uh must be acknowledged before granting
a loan to any
uh cons customers or any anyone
and this this process is followed at
every bank so
there is a one traditional lending
process is there so in past
like there is a highly skilled
professional was
was hired and they they their whole
purpose is basically to evaluate the
applicant and
they analyze their uh background and
they review their background
and on that basis they used to fix some
credit score
and on that basis they they used to take
a decision whether they have to grant
the loan to the customer or they
or whether they don't want to grant a
loan to the customer so on
that credit base is basically generated
by the skilled profession
professional in that field so
then the credit score is is is being
created
and which basically help the
authorization to take a decision in
granting the law
and also this this is like a very time
consuming process
and traditionally it was being followed
and now the modern
way is a like machine learning technique
and deep learning algorithms
are being incorporated and it is being
adopted by many of the
banks and which basically automatically
predict the credit scores of applicant
based on their historical credit data
and their historical credit histories so
now the credit scores are generated by
looking at the historical data of the
person
and historical database by machine and
by machine learning technique or deep
learning techniques so this is the
modern way of
analyzing the credit score and then
granting the loan
to the right customer
um coming to the application of machine
learning
their various application of a machine
learning is being
now is used in banking domain and
financial domain one comes a fraud
detection
uh this is the fraud detection uh in the
most of the banking has the problem
where they are facing the high uh
for detection so machine learning
technique helping the product detection
to analyze the fraud at
early stages and then providing a high
security
to the customer and their employees
there is a lifetime value prediction and
in lifetime value prediction basically
it deals with a kind of value businesses
and will which drive from their entire
relationship with customer
so basically analyzing customer behavior
patterns and then
uh giving a high value to their their
assets and then and helping them and
basically retaining your customer at a
good point
and then rick's modeling comes one of
the application of machine learning in
banking is a risk modeling as well
verdicts are being analyzed
and one is customer support like machine
learning is used in customer support for
providing high standards support to
their customers
and one of the application is this as
well and customer segmentation so
basically machine learning
a bit uh help in a customer segmentation
as well
uh basically it analyzing the right
customer
a right group of customer based on some
demographical patterns
or some traits and patterns and trends
and offering the some kind of
personalized marketing system to those
kind of customers those
group of customers there comes a
customer segmentation so these are the
customer segmentation where
the people are grouped together and then
personalized
offerings are being offered so my this
project is also based on one of the
application of machine learning
technique only
so in this project as uh through this
seminar
as my aim is to predict a default loan
defaulter rate using machine learning
technique
the aim of this project and objective of
this project is to find the probability
of default
rate well in advance using machine
learning
technique on the various factors are
involved in
uh the various factors are involved in
risks analytics of
loan defaulters so yeah it also consists
of
developing the understanding the
behavior of pattern of customer before
granting loan so basically it means
first understanding the customer's
behavior and their
background and then granting a loan and
this technique reduces and minimizes the
borrower defaulting loan using machine
learning techniques the risks of
borrowing the loan and the third outcome
the aid of financial firms uh it
basically
help financial firms to take more uh
informed credit score decisions and and
uh
based on that they can reduce the
default rate in the future
so this is uh about this project and
aims
i hope i just would like to ask one
thing here to everyone i hope
you have got a brief about the loan
defaulter and
why the defaulters comes up play a risk
at
banking yeah so one of the techies chris
dear methodology is there like
it's a one of the christian technique in
which is a basically
data science step is being followed as
per this methodology
i have applied a christian technique in
this first comes a business
understanding to understand the business
problem
and so these are six different steps are
there here i have done five different
five steps for this analysis the first
come a data understanding it's the one
of the steps which play a very important
role in a machine learning and data
science pipeline
uh to understand the data carefully
which means uh it's
very important to understand data
carefully before doing
any analysis the third step comes a data
pre-processing
basically data pre-processing is a step
where the
whenever we get a data uh it all present
in a raw format or unstructured form
it's very important to do a convert into
the structure format
before doing it any analysis but there
so this is the step
of one of the steps of data pipeline
where it um
data pre-processing comes in a picture
and uh
when we process the data from uh uh
convert data from structure to non-stuck
um
from non-structured data into structured
format so basically converting data in a
finished format from
the raw and better making it better for
the analysis
then comma modeling here is a modeling
the technique which comes a machine
learning technique
and this is the machine learning
techniques uh
it can be various machine learning
techniques are there
such as logistic regression and
linear regressions and the various
machine learning techniques are
are in um presently in supervised
learning as well and also unsupervised
learning as well
both have a different way of using it
and
and depending upon the business problems
uh
and then comes the evaluation technique
and uh there there is always a way to
evaluate
the uh the result we have got
and on the basis of that we can we can
make analysis like
the model which we have built on our uh
and our solving this business problem is
right or wrong
so this is about evaluation this five
steps i have followed for this
and so in data preprocessing as i was
talking about data preprocessing a step
of converting the data from
our unstructured data to into structured
format it has a first
following these steps so in data
gathering and consolidation cleaning
exploration and transformation
feature selection and the modeling so as
i told
data gathering and consolidation is
nothing but a gathering of data
i will be explaining these things in
detail in later later slides the
upcoming slides
and then comes our data cleaning uh data
cleaning is a process of
cleaning the data unwanted information
should be removed that's
one of the step of data cleaning and
then comes a data exploration
data exploration is basically uh
exploring the data
what data is basically would like to
tell that is a data exploration
part and then transformation uh is there
basically
why we need a transformation there is a
need of transformation
because uh all the data are in a
different format and we have to convert
the data into
uh one format so it's very important to
convert into the one
format so that's a transformation comes
and the feature selection is basically a
step
where uh like uh okay i give you an
example here
in future selection what happened a lot
of uh whenever we deal with
any business problem the lot of few data
features are present features are
nothing but uh
different parameters are affecting our
one target variables
so like in this problem is there the
target variable is where the person will
able to
pay or loan or repay the loan or not
back to the com
bank so but there are there will be
various factors will be there
that will be affecting that particular
target
so that is like we have to select
important features which is only making
a significant impact for our target
variable
and which is basically it means a
significant impact to uh
which help us to do this analysis
whether the person will able to pay the
loan or back or not
and then there comes a modeling
technique which is a part of machine
learning which models we should be
applying for this techniques
so uh software i used a microsoft
office and uh uh as st and i did a
modeling and everything in our studio
so that is a software and
as uh i have taken a data from uh open
linked
repository leading club website and this
is the website you can get a such kind
of data of
dealing with loans and borrowers data
you can find it here
and this data has a historical data from
2007 to 2019 and data were present in a
csv format
and there there are others source of the
link as well for the data
such as kagger and uci machine learning
uh so if
you are guys are doing your project or
they are going doing your similar kind
of project you can get it data from the
kaggle and you share machine as well
and so data understanding um i will be
showing you the data as well so as in
data understanding like
as data consist when i downloaded data
from this leading club it was having the
information from 2007 to 2011
and the decline loan rate was from 2007
to 12 and the data had
one for four columns so there were one
one four four column were present
and it was having 42k records um
yeah i'll just show you
yeah so it was having this much of the
columns
and as you can see these columns having
a lot of
uh missing informations here and these
are just column and
the there is no data present here and uh
and a few of the columns have a good
amount of data
yeah so that's a reason we have to deal
with this kind of information as well
that's
here comes the data cleaning yeah
so uh yeah so it has a 144 column and
42k
record uh and in my actual sheet
and yes these are the columns and
records
so
and data cleaning uh
yeah uh in data cleaning as i told like
they were having lot of na value were
present
and there were fifty percent of columns
were there that which was not containing
any information
so there is no information there's no uh
they cannot do any analysis on that
so that's the reason i removed those
fifty percent of
column which were containing n a values
and from one four four column i left
with a 53
columns only and
yeah so then again you can see here as
uh to the code one four column where
there and it got reduced to
53 and then uh i also deal with outlier
basically outlier is something which
makes your data biased towards something
and
outlier which or doesn't make any uh
yeah so outliers it is very very
important to deal with outlier as well
there are some data points are very
far from the mean i removed those
outliers
and cut it down from my original data
set
and uh there were very there was many
many duplicates value were present in my
data set ticket means
repeated information it doesn't make we
one information is enough for that we
there's no need to have a some similar
kind of information two to three times
so i removed
through a duplicate technique is there
to remove it then
uh there is a missing value
there is one column revlon revolve
until and uh it was having a lot of
missing values i removed that column and
there was
not left with 766 and then there
were some call variables uh which was i
renamed those variables in a proper
format of loan
and because uh to for better visibility
so this is the data cleaning step so it
is being basically done to
convert your data into a structured
format and then performing a modeling
uh so i will be taking you through the
data exploration part
uh this is the one of one of the
exploration uh
i did so first and then uh
this is the exploity data analysis where
our data
we are doing a data visualization here
so i did here
a data visualization for the loan amount
this is the the one of the column which
is a
loan amount is one of the columns
basically a feature you can say uh when
i did
property analysis of a loan amount i
found that
the majority of loan is falling from
eight thousand
and fifteen thousand and
uh this is the uh graph which tells the
the basically um
minimum and for minimum amount is 500
and maximum is three five zero zero
and there is a medium value and mean
value as well so
mean of this loan amount is one one zero
zero
one one zero nine zero and and it tells
that first
this is the first uh quartile and this
third quartile which basically tells
that majority of loans
falls from uh uh five to zero zero and
uh fifteen zero
fifteen zero zero one or or 8 000 it was
basically
and from 15 minutes now yeah so and
going by i'm going ahead with uh under
exported data analysis this is the other
analysis i did and visualize the fact
i visualize the data of my uh
data and data analysis so this is like a
loan status
bar plot uh in this um
you can see there but there is a one
loan status a column is there i
did a data visualization of that
particular column using a bar plot this
is a bar plot
uh there is a one fully paid loan and uh
3604 are the fully paid loans and
there is a charge of
yeah the uh this charge of of uh
five six seven zero which is 17 fully
paid means uh the person who has already
paid their loan after taking the loan
from the bank
and charged off basically means the
person has taken the loan but
they are not able to pay it back and
they are being charged off
due to some reason so our main analysis
of whether they're able to pay it no
so so here comes a picture of charged
off
yeah so this is the other visualization
i did uh like where i was analyzing our
loan value by years
and i found uh like issue that i made a
one
in this bar this is a basically a
stacked bar
chart and uh in this i showed a
various different grades where they're
in my data set and i showed data with
respect to ear
so this visualization told me that
like there is a when i was doing
analysis for 36 months and
60 months basically 360 years later
three years so it tells like 36 months
people are more interested at taking the
loan in for three years
and all the classes uh like the abc are
different classes are there
so they are taking they're more
interested in taking the loan for 36
months
like basically three years and very less
number of people are there a very small
number of people out there who are
taking the loan for
60 months this is basically 60 months i
hope you can see it
yeah yeah
so six uh six it's a 60 month like so a
majority of people are taking loan for
three years
uh so this analysis came out of this
visualization
and one visualization i also did uh
in which this is the tree map for the
purpose of loan and
where i want you to know what is the
purpose of loan
people are taking the loan from the bank
where i found that
there is a one is a debit card and
debit consolidation and
credit card and other is a home
improvement
yeah so other is a home improvement um
yes
so these are the three reasons debit
consolidation credit card and home
improvement
but the majority where the people were
taking the loan so these
are major purposes so to make it this uh
tree um
map i consider three values like uh
average
amount of the loan and total volume of
the loan
and with the average amounts
then comes a stack column chart this is
the one that's other
data visualization and where
i have made yeah so in this uh basically
uh where
what i have showed like there is a one
you can see here
this is non-verified there's a source
verified and verified basically this
visualization represents that
non-verified cases are there
source verified cases are there and
verified cases are there
and it in verified cases also there are
the majority of charge date is high
basically
even the cases were verified before
granting the loan
but still it says that they are not
being paid back to the
com banks so what can be the reason
behind that so this is the
this is one of the major risks can be
there so we have to analyze that
so this is the other chart i have
created one at the bar chart and with
respect to the state
and uh yes with respect to the state and
uh this is uh with all stated
and this other graph i sold with loan
status
and like where i distributed where i
showed that loan status
with respect to loan status and the
grades
as well and i have in this graph there
is it is having a grade of
all the people as well the loan status
taken by them
and the different charge off
so this is the one of the other graph
which basically tells
the yeah this is the other graph which
basically area which i plotted for the
three different sectors
mortrage and own and the rent which
basically means that
uh people are who are having or mortrage
and the rents they are taking these are
these are basically
grade of the classes
class a class b class c a g and so
this graph represents that mortgage and
the rent have more demand
of borrowing the money from the banks
and those who already have their own
houses
and they are well settled people they
are don't have much and
they are borrowing less amount of yeah
or they were
they are not preferring to borrow money
from the banks
so this graph given a brief disc
description about mortrage owned in the
rent so the person who's already having
more fridge own and rent
so as i told in the beginning like we
had a one
one four four columns and then after
performing a data cleaning basically
removing unwanted things from the data
we left with 53 columns
and after doing a data visualization we
we found that there are various
variables are there various features are
there which is important for our further
analysis
so uh this this is our target variable
loan status whether people are
able to pay the loan or not and uh
and all conversion has and it has all
conversion and the
means basically uh there and then i i
left with 18 columns only
and after the further
data visualization these 18 columns
where
one was the lone status other is a grade
sub grade
means basically grade abc classes can be
there
and public and uh two year of data last
six months of data annual income can be
one of the reason also the person who's
having their own house can be the reason
and purpose what purpose they are taking
the loan their addresses
how much amount they are taking and
interested installment and their
previous balance and previous uh
so these are the following target i gave
for the further analysis
so for this um technique uh using
machine learning i have applied
uh logistic regression navi bias and
random forest
and i first i splitted the data into two
parts
first into training sets and tested
basically this is uh
um which basically um is a from the our
entire data set we giving it to the
machine to
analyze it first as the data was already
labeled
labeled
means uh data was already having the
information about
few of the information from the
historical data having the information
about
a person will able to pay the loan one
as i
have labeled it already i have labeled a
fully paid those who have a fully paid
the loan
uh them one and those who have charged
or
i have given a zero representation for
that why i have given this in a
numerical format only because the
machine doesn't understand the
uh the category means the categorical
values it only understand the numerical
values it's very important to convert it
into the
machine formats so that's the reason i
converted from full i have
basically labeled those fully paid two
in one and
charged off to the zero and uh
and then i splitted the data there was
from all hundred months
from all the data i split it into the
category of 70 percent of training self
which basically means
i given 70 percent of data from my
entire data sets to the machine
to tight and and to tell machine to
learn from those training sets
and and testing set for 30 to
30 data assigned for the testing sets
basically to check the whether it's
performing well on testing data as well
or not
uh i have applied machine learning a
logistic regression which works very
well for the classification
problem as this is a classification
problem by this i mean that
uh classification points uh uh i give i
um basically it's um suppose i want to
do
um whether there will be disease or not
yes or no
female or male so this kind of uh are
the classification problem so here as
per our business problem is basically a
classification problem
whether a person will be fully we will
pay it or
not paid so this is charged off so this
is a uh
zero and one or defaulter or
non-defaulter
zero or one so yeah that's the reason
after logistic
regression and i have applied navi bias
and this is the problem which
also works very well with a which tells
the probability of
both the classes one or zero and random
forest as well
so uh when i applied machine learning
technique the following uh uh
result was achieved through this um
in this analysis of mine i found that
logistic regression
gave 85 percent of accuracy in terms of
uh in the in while predicting the
defaulter and on deporter uh and
in iv bias it has given a 76.03 percent
and random forest 44.57 so the random
part doesn't perform very well for this
kind of data set
and logistic regression is among this
performed very well and it
has given uh in uh offers 85 percent of
the accuracy so it was quite good and
means i have also calculated the
evaluation metrics
which i will be showing in your code
yeah
okay so i was here so when i applied a
machine learning technique to my
um this um this approach so
i i found like logitech regression was
working very well and it was giving
85 percent of accuracy and the error was
also less
um and uh and there were also other two
technique of machine learning i have
applied one
was navi by another was random forest
navy voice given um 76.03
of accuracy and random forest
was not able to perform better it has
given a
44.57 of accuracy so i sticked with a
logistic regression
and yeah so here i was
so basically uh yeah so these are the
supporting libraries i have uploaded
in order to support my analysis and
these other like gg plot
uh which basically helps to do a data
visualizations and
these are the um some energy models
which supports
logistic regression and navi biases all
and machine learning models so first i
given a path i
assigned a path using this technique uh
as that
asset wd and i run this so it got fixed
once basically it means that it has
extracted the data from my
excel and then i read i'm reading this
my data set um my data set name is loan
stat uh
csv in data exploration as
it was having 114 column so as i told in
my slides i am doing it
through code as well
here you can see it is having a
a total observation of 42k observation
was there and it was having one one four
variables
and um yes so first uh
yeah so i removed the na values a lot of
basically this is the step where i was
doing the data cleaning
and
so basically uh there were a lot of
missing value represent lot of
unwanted information which is not
required from analysis so i removed all
those things
uh so uh so now i'm um
yeah so through this code density or i
i was checking the loan density and
i can see that this visualization will
come which basically tells the amount of
loan falling from a the mean is mean of
this
yeah it from 8 000 to 5 1500 majority of
density of loan amount is between this
range only
so basically means people are taking a
loan off from
8000 to 1500 15 000 sorry
and uh um then i checked the n a
of for the loans uh loan
start loan start def is basically um
one of the data means it's converting
things into data from i'm checking that
is
is there and this code means is there
any any information present in loan
status or not
and then i did visualization of for
loans stat df and where you can see that
um
this is this everything i showed in your
visualization only as well
so fully paid in information
three four one zero zero i guess yeah
and
then charged off cases are this much and
uh
as uh that then i uh i only end after
doing analysis and
all all the rest of the analysis are
present in my github repository
and i have kept everything over there
and i have only kept few things over
here
and as the select i select and and from
114
they were not everyone important for our
further analysis so i only
selected the important
important variables for the analysis
such as loan status grade and this
so i i just run it for you these are the
relevant features which is important for
our target where i keep this
and then i i
this i i kept in one variable these are
the following variables uh
which were important for further
analysis i come i
took into other variables and i passed
in one of the
uh variable and data frame and
selected these following features so we
can see now we having
these variables of 17 variables along
with that one target variable
so basically everything is i'm here
showing you is all about
what i have told in represent in my
presentation already
this is basically the coding part of
that or deleting the empty rows i'm just
giving you the brief idea so it will
help you
whenever you will be doing by yourself
and so merging the target column is
there
as i told that there was one charge off
and full leap and basically you know
default and on default so here uh i
merge those target value you can run by
yourself
you can say following cases came out and
then uh this is the
point where i was uh i will run for you
where i converted the data into
these other these are the variables loan
amount
um these are the variables by
this i mean these are the variables
these are the features
so all where in um categorical format i
converted into numerical formats so
a number of formats so they can my
machine can
i can give it to machine and not it will
be easy for
them to run the code so
i check that it says that there's no any
uh
any value present so data is completely
cleaned and then i
um just a minute
yeah and then i made a machine learning
model uh
where i did a splitting of
0.0.7 and 0.3 and where i basically
divided a data center training pattern
testing part
training data will make uh will maintain
the data
and the testing part will be there to
test whatever the training is being done
by machine learning or model or
basically your system
uh is it performing well on test data as
well that is because of for test
testing data that's the reason we split
data into 70 to 30 20 percent 30
percentile yeah
and then i applied logistic regression
and this is the glm is a
model and uh where i when i apply
logistic regression
uh supports and then um
yeah just a minute yeah
yeah so i run it for you so this is the
logitech regression this basically fit
what is this is basically doing other it
is fitting the
training data to the machine by logistic
regression technique
so in this way it will take some time to
get
run and then
yeah so yeah so it is basically this
actual
predictor value is one of the confusion
metrics which is one of the evaluation
technique for the machine learning
and i can also see from this i have
calculated the accuracy as well
and we have got a like good or 85
percent of accuracy for
eye for this project and similarly i did
it for uh
um for navi bias as well and also for
the
uh random forest as well and uh but
a random first didn't perform much
better it didn't able to
take uh yeah and uh yeah even the roc
cover
basically this is the curve which was
better for the logistic regression so i
stick with the logistic regression with
87 percent was quite good accuracy and
even the
confusion matrix it was quite good so
this is all about
the brief description of the how i did
it incorporated it with
my coding of r you can also do it in a
python
as well and it's the motor handy in
python as well
so and i have also provided the links
where you can
get your data by yourself and try it
by yourself
fine there i just moved
yeah okay so four minutes until the
break
would you like to take some questions
from the audience yeah and so thank you
for
this this is about all about my
presentation
uh any question guys
yeah i can see there's the one person
has posted um
i cannot see the hole
i have a question
in your confusion matrix it looked like
almost
all was predicted as once
[Music]
so
[Music]
i mean of course if the data set is
biased you have a high accuracy
did you look at other metrics as well
other than accuracy
no uh well i have already did a balance
of data set with the seed technique
that's the rose technique
and uh yeah so yeah accuracy for um for
logistic recreation was good
for the navi bias and the random forest
it was not quite good
and yeah
okay one question i found
uh yeah was it this kaggle data set uh
i i have taken this data set from the
lending club and uh you
there are a lot of data set as well
present uh present from usci
and kaggle you can take it from there as
well
and um yes
you can do with uh uh like you can
prefer any language it won't be issue
like whether it's our python
i did it in python as well and i did it
in r
as well so it's not an issue you can
have a look at my github repository
uh it would be helpful like if you have
any question guys you can ping me on
my linkedin uh i will definitely try to
answer your question
more and uh yeah and you can give me
suggestions as well definitely and i
will be definitely learning from you as
well
so feel free to contact me anytime on my
linkedin
any other question guys
i have one question yes yes sure
yes you said at the beginning that
you something about deep learning and
predicting
loans did you also check some
neural nets or something like that
within your loan data
yeah sure yes please don't go ahead
yeah because i mean logistic regression
they already use it in the banks quite
heavily
so i'm wondering if you go one step
ahead one step ahead
yeah yeah definitely i i i got you like
this is not like my company's
uh like data set i decided for my own
purpose so yeah definitely
there are many other advanced techniques
now being uh adopted by bank and
uh this is like there are many advance
are there so
so this is just for the basic purpose
and i have yeah
uh any suggestion like you want me to
apply i will definitely apply
are you aware of any of the techniques
which you're talking about
no that poster is my masking
okay no no problem yes sure i i
i feel like there are actually i read it
couple of articles like there are many
other different techniques as well are
there
so uh like i never in uh i didn't uh
on this date as i didn't did that so i
didn't showed
you i'll definitely try and i will
definitely uh add
that point as well and later i will be
showing you
or i will post it you as yeah
yeah i'm very curious about it because
in the banking industry they have a
different problem as well
because loan default models they must
go to a official in austria it's called
the
the fmr and the and they must present
their models there and so it's not
enough to have a nice model in the house
you
also the other part needs to understand
it that yeah
yes i completely agree so it's uh like
depending on the business problem
uh things differ it's not like logitech
regression will work
for better for everything to be very
honest or
so so it's all depend upon the different
kind of business problem we are dealing
with and what kind of issue and what are
the constraint are there
so a different techniques are being
applied everywhere
and it's not being particular like one
technique is working fine
for one kind of data it will work for
time for other kind of data as well
so depending upon the complexity
depending upon the kind of problem
depending on what kind of data we are
having and dealing with so techniques
changes
my techniques changes machine learning
changes deep learning changes
so these things
i hope i answered your yeah thanks
what's your name uh i i cannot see on uh
benjamin
i hope uh i answered you
okay if so there's no more question i
think we should
we're only two minutes late i think it's
time for a break
yes uh okay thank you guys everyone and
uh you can contact me on my linkedin i
have
i can give you iphone my linkedin as
well i have posted in my linkedin
so it will helpful for you to get me
keep me in contact and i will definitely
you can also give me a suggestion i will
appreciate you that suggestion and take
it
as a positive way and definitely trying
to work it on that as well